Latria. Once an ivory tower, now, the city has
become the stuff of nightmares. New prisoners are
locked up and tortured in the Prison of Hope, then
told to seek redemption up above. There is none.
Instead, gargoyles take them to the upper city,
where they will inevitably join the rest of the
bodies dumped into a sea of flesh and blood.
Tentacles absorb the repulsive mix of remains,
feeding a gargantuan ball of flesh. This heart
of Latria spits out chimeric abominations,
each with the face of a former
prisoner, contorted in agony.
Behind it all is the Golden Elder, a
former noble. Consequences be damned,
he will have his revenge.
Rydell screams, echoes,
as the video begins.
In Demon's Souls, magic benefits from one's
intelligence. The more clearly you are able to
comprehend something, the more powerful your magic
becomes. Latria clearly had a focus on science
and experimentation - look to the equipment in
their towers, and even on their archstone..for
proof of that. It set them apart from others
known to have practiced the Soul Arts - like
the Monumentals, who practiced through faith
That's not to say that Latria didn't have a
culture of worship as well. They absolutely
did. Look at what's depicted on the queen's
throne - a woman representing royal authority,
her body emanating light while a Pegasus glides
through the heavens; all symbols of divinity and
spiritual freedom. The Queen was the holiest of
holies, a being of supreme magical and therefore:
divine power. The bridge between man, and god.
Perhaps they were looking to cross that bridge.
The researchers and sages of the Ivory
Tower elevated themselves to aristocrat,
believing they deserved to enjoy the finer things
as well [[Silverwork Bracelets, Aged Spice,
Fresh Spice]]. For who better to stand beside
the Queen, than men of similar knowledge?
I was once the wife of nobility, and I
have some nice things to show for it.
To be clear - these were not royals, they were
nobles. Not family, but clan. Thus, since they
weren't born into power, it was possible to obtain
it. One way was to strive to be intelligent,
like the queen [[monumental dialogue]], but
another was to simply become wealthier. Though..
when your currency is souls, that can
quickly become a dark desire indeed.
The Silver Bracelets we find in Latria boost
the amount of souls you receive, and they're
an example of how the rich get richer. Mankind is
greedy, always lusting for more, and some, like a
certain old man, would do anything to ascend.
It was this exact same lust for power,
that triggered the First Scourge. But it
wasn't Latria that triggered that. Instead,
it was the Monumentals.
Luckily, the Old One was sealed away
by the same monumentals - and the world learned
to fear the power they had toyed with. And even
though it was the bedrock of their society,
Latria joined them in forbidding such knowledge.
The Ivory Tower's magical studies were over.
Without something to strive for, they were
bereft of direction. All they had now, was
their queen, and a backstabbing aristocracy.
During this age, Latria became a dangerous
place indeed. Assassination became a part of
their political culture, and the weapons
that facilitate these dark deeds can be
found all throughout the city [[Mercury Rapier,
Baby's Nail, Needle of Eternal Agony]]. Nobles
famously took to wearing the red lotus; partly
for its beauty, but mostly because it's a quick
cure for poison [[Noble's Lotus]]. Even
absent magic, man's malice remained.
Far better suited to this post-magic world
was Boletaria, whose raw military strength
allowed them to expand their borders. Evidence
of their spies can even be found within Latria,
suggesting the Ivory Tower might
have been next on their list.
Luckily for Latria, the Soul was rediscovered
by Boletaria, who flourished thanks to its arts.
In order to tip the scales back in their favour,
the Queen made the decision to restore the Ivory
Tower - restart research which had for so long
collected dust. Latria would once again become
a beacon of academia, and this time, it was
a wise man named Freke who led the way.
A former priest, Freke systemised the Soul
Arts into an academic framework for anyone
to learn He is known as the "Sage of Yormedaar",
a distinguished school in Latria where the rich
and privileged from all over came to learn the
soul arts - including you, if you chose a noble
background. Freke would go on to travel, spreading
his methods and the fame of the Yormedaar school
far and wide. Now, in this new world where
magic was allowed, Latria had power and
influence - even gifting ornate armaments to a
certain prince of Boletaria when he came touring
in its borders. They were finally safe
from external forces like Boletaria..but
turns out, it was those at home that they
should have been more concerned about.
Among the noble researchers, there
was an elderly man who went too far.
His obsession with souls crossed the
line, and he likely even dabbled in
human experimentation [[Source: his later
exploits]], extracting vast amount of souls from
others . You'll recall - it was this exact same
thirst for power that awoke the Old One eons ago.
So, the Queen banished this high-ranking member
of the Ivory Tower. It was the right thing to do,
but it couldn't have backfired more horribly.
Around this time, during his exile, the Old One
was awoken by the exact same lust for power
in King Allant of Boletaria, which triggered
the second scourge. Demons returned to the
land, and as if like magic, a golden cloth
emerged from the fog - a demon, with the power
to make the elderly man's dreams a reality.
The Queen banished her depraved
old man from the land.
He returned in strange golden
garb with foul Demons in tow.
They pillaged great Latria, land of the
learned, and shut us away in this prision.
Garbed in that regal colour, the old
man ravaged Latria, killed its Queen,
and and imprisoned all who were a part of her
ruling clan. To help enforce his new rule, broken
servants channel rudimentary spells throughout the
city, sustaining a horrific system of sacrifice.
They are protected by former noblemen who
forsook their pride and patriotism to join
the winning side - Magicians, who transformed
into the octopus-headed Jailers, still carrying
expensive spices, and wearing their old robes.
Since then, they've been feeding off our souls…
Telling us over and over that if we go
above, we will be granted redemption.
The Queen is alive, they say. Right there in
the church up above. Go up and see for yourself.
She is immortal, rising over and over again.
Those who survive the cruel torture and traps
arrive to praise their undying goddess, never
noticing the servant pulling the strings.
To a hopeless, soul-siphoned Latrian,
it must sound all too tempting.
Then come the gargoyles, the souls of Latrian
soldiers and knights inserted in the local
statues, to drag worshippers of this Fool’s
Idol up to the horror behind the holy veneer.
The old man is making the prisoners take part
in his perverse experiments - creating demons,
and fulfilling his role as an archdemon of the
Old One. No one can stop his revenge. Not even
Freke himself, who returns to Latria only
to be locked up in a cell like the rest.
I was defeated and captured by the
golden elder beyond that dungeon.
Beware of him, for he manipulates souls.
He has power over dark souls,
those susceptible to madness and paranoia.
The Elder may be powerful, yet the golden cloth
he wears is still a demon. Its power is not his
own, and his soul hardly matches its appetite. The
cloth seeks a new vessel to control with paranoia
and mania, and will abandon the old man to die
once it has found that more worthy body.
For..the goal of Demonkind is not to elevate
humanity to their status. It's to wipe
them out and obscure everything in fog.
That's the cost of power here, and for
some, it's a worthy price to pay.
Why, you have defeated all
the demons, have you not?
This ghastly howl. The Monumental
has spoken of it before…
There is a question I have long had in my mind
It is whether we are right to banish the Old One
And I now have the answer,
and it is a resounding no.
Listen closely. The Old One
must not be cut off from us.
If the candle maiden tries
to entrap it, kill her.
Then Absorb the souls of
the Old One for yourself.
The Old one is an unfathomable deposit of energy,
it contains all the souls collected by the Demons
You will gain the power of a King, and
I will gain knowledge from beyond.
And that, my dear friend, is the righteous path.
You must not allow trifling
matters to dissuade you.
The Demon souls shall be ours!
A lot of you are probably watching this video
on an iPhone..and if you'd like to learn about
the fascinating man who created the first one,
then I'd highly recommend Steve Jobs, an
exclusive biography by Walter Isaacson,
on Audible. While you listen to this sample, go
and visit Audible dot com slash vaatividya or text
vaatividya to five hundred five hundred, to start
your free trial and get one free audiobook.
I'm sure you've heard or read about Steve Jobs
online..and one thing that always struck me was
that those comments are either full of intense
praise for the man and his accomplishments, or
they're dismissive of him, calling him a terrible
person for how he treated other people. After
listening to this audiobook, you'll realise that
both comments are kind of true, but neither are
the full picture. This audiobook gives a balanced
insight into a fascinating person who really did
change the world, and some quotes from this
audiobook have stuck with me for years afterwards.
This was the first audiobook that really got me
into Audible, and I think you'll enjoy it.
Remember: your membership also includes access to
the Plus catalogue, which grants unlimited access
to thousands of select originals, audiobooks and
podcasts. No matter what you're into - they've
got it. So again, go and visit Audible dot com
slash vaatividya or text vaatividya to five
hundred five hundred, to get started today..and
thank you, to Audible, for sponsoring this video."